today we are starting a new series
business principles 101 if you just want
to replace your income by doing
something you enjoy doing
you can absolutely sell some kind of
expertise or even sell what you're
currently doing but package it in a
business if you want to become good at
business a formal education is in no way
mandatory people love the idea of being
an entrepreneur or a business owner more
than they like the idea of doing
business means they want the title
without the graft if the title could be
attained overnight in that case it's not
worth anything so you shouldn't want it
I've seen people set up a blog or a
YouTube channel and really plow money
into it and try and get the production
quality working and just get nothing out
of it because you can't rely on organic
traffic being a thing not anymore if you
just do for a living what you find
intensely interesting then immediately
you have a massive advantage over
everybody else we're not actually that
good at business but we've made 13 years
of mistakes that we only made once
I'm joined by none other than Joni a new
safe from propane fitness calm welcome
back welcome back indeed um today we are
starting a new series business
principles 101 we have all had a lot of
experience I've done 13 years of
business operating you've had nearly a
decade now
eleven eleven Johnny something similar
it's like thirty years of combined
running and failing at business lots of
Fame opening daily we get quite a lot of
requests for advice for entrepreneurship
and stuff like that and I figured the
wealth of experience that we have both
good and bad
could be pretty valuable to people and
there should be some golden stories that
come out of this also all of us did
business degrees of one sort or another
sort of yeah accounting what was your
actual degree economics was it okay and
then you did - maths and business both
totally useless as far as application
but I think something that's really
useful as well of hearing our failings
that are to come is that if you ever
want to learn something from someone I
think if you've got a choice between
learning from someone who is a natural
and just struck lucky first time
compared to someone who was terrible or
may failed multiple times and grew into
a stage that you've seen this
progression there's so much more to be
learned from that person like like we
were saying in relationships 103 where
the guy who's been divorced 15 times
knows a lot more about marriage then the
guy that just happened to look into a
harmonious one.you always say this about
mobility right you want to learn from
the guy who couldn't get into good squat
position bench press but I tried it yeah
you don't want to learn from the guy
with little arms you want to live from
the guy who's world record level but
it's got really long arms grinded it out
yeah yeah cool so um where do we start
with business principles I guess come on
I'm I don't want a hot potato you Johnny
you are going
sorry I apologize also before we get
before we get cracking in the comments
below or message me on instagram if
there's any particular areas of business
that you want us to cover any stories
you want us to elaborate on any advice
you'd like us to go forward with
entrepreneurship or our experiences or
if you need an accountant I've got mint
accountant as well so just you know
magic man precise so Johnny what was
your first foray into entrepreneurship
or business operating so I I was sat
watching TV one summer I think still at
school perhaps and used to read tea
nation bodybuilding.com a lot and
clearly you remember the thought of that
that can't be that difficult to do like
it's just a website with a lot of cousin
Fitness yeah let's do that text you said
why actually started one myself
unlike blog spot.com I want to he's like
really old now websites they allow you
to set a really bad website text Yusef
and said should we set up a website
we'll call it optimum Fitness
systems.com and you I remember you were
like you were super keen mmm-hmm but you
googled how many results optimum Fitness
systems came up it was like hundred and
this is probably what like 2008 2006
copy before the 2006 dozen so here's you
so yeah so now option them if you I
think if there's our first piece of
advice you I think you're on say do not
call it opportunity Ottoman fitness
system yeah yeah so that was it that was
it and it didn't become a business until
2011 you know so yeah so you guys you
just started the bloggers like ah oh we
do fitness people ask us when you get
hassled loads about yes okay well I
think when you're like the the fit one
your friends and your friendship group
people ask you like you know I don't
know I got big arms are we in the
morning to schools strawberry and
I get corners in the gym oh excuse me
just it is just sure you know I have me
breakfast 7:00 a.m. strawberry two
scoops
[Laughter]
you don't like well it's too rude to
interject at this point so I don't have
to wait until he makes this point
Organic IO GI some girl outside of
voodoo on Saturday opened every sentence
that she said to me said about maybe
five different things every sentence was
opened with not being funny play it and
then zoom in on his mouth and you'll
hear him go every sentence was opened
whether not being funny let's see that
that was just a private joke because we
were a thing where there's a guy
constantly who've annoyed asking I'm not
being funny right but no one laughed so
there was no danger of anyone thinking
it was funny this is hilarious but I
promise you it's not intended to be
humorous at all just a breakfast early
warning system has been activated yeah
so any weird um so yeah that was what
about you Yousef did you do any install
that I ate the dropship batteries on
eBay was like fails when he told us that
you'd be going to like fly for 12:30
Holt right dropship I bet you still do
battery conference last weekend that's
where you were you weren't would you go
from you in the cottage so my first
principles Manya yeah Rock shipped but I
actually have misused the word dropship
if I arbitrage them
that's even worse so you never actually
owned them
well I owned and throat for a short time
so I used to buy batteries in bulk the
little c-137 or whatever they scales
yeah so yeah he's to buy them in bulk
and then resell them such a bore like
actually not so that was lesson number
one time is money and just because you
can make a mark up on something doesn't
mean that that profit is worth your time
because if you translate that into if
you just get a job in a purple and
Koster or something you probably make
more per hour with less stress and so
what would you mark up on me but it was
a can't remember nah it wasn't worth my
time not enough to continue doing no
just because of the amount of bought a
car either yeah so talking about the
issue of time I think this paralysis by
analysis issue that we came up against
or what me and one of the guys part of
modern wisdom project Jordan dubbed the
planners dilemma similar to the
prisoner's dilemma is a lot of people
are averse to starting a business
because they would rather plan and all
the things that yeah the perfect
business whereas definitely young we
will all agree that a lot of the skills
that you learn in business just occur
from operating something yeah like just
having to deal with the situations which
arise as a byproduct of having a
business and they become so robust and
transferable so great principle for this
is idea is the const
an execution is the multiplier whereas a
lot of people who haven't done something
like this before thinks that think that
the idea is like oh I've got this really
sick idea you've got to sign a
nondisclosure agreement if you're gonna
talk about it with me because I'll have
to kill you if it and it's like no one
cares about your stupid little idea
because unless you actually execute it
well it don't like Amazon selling stuff
selling items online it's not it's not a
groundbreaking idea but it's executed so
well yeah then it becomes so I think
that's something that and it comes into
the panel style Emma because people
think they're like if they craft this
perfect idea it's like but actually if
they just got moving and doing things
and then fail forward into stuff and
then you figure out what works and what
doesn't I think the best description of
iterative business operation is just
professional problem-solving yeah and
like you all all that happens is you are
trying to make something continue
happening and happened more or faster
more often or a bigger bigger scale and
loads of problems happen but feels
assault each time something happens
there's a problem finally switching the
RS create another problem yeah it feels
like it's up to me controlled falling
business like someone's pushed you at
the top of an infinite set of stairs and
all you're doing is going so we have a
friend who run a bike company and he was
consulted he got a phone call the other
day of someone being like oh you right
mate something's gone wrong in the labs
like they're the inducer isn't working
through the thing and it's letting off
this blue steam and then was like okay
so maybe just try this and then or get
Christian's write a bit of code so that
I only functions are intermittently like
been what how do you know about lab
equipment he was like I don't really
it's just kind of system yeah at some
point in its history he's come up with
something that links to this but yet
controlled falling man like again a lot
of people that think they perceive
professionals high performing
professionals as being good at business
would be so amazed to realize how little
of a clue they have about what they're
doing so it's listening to and this is a
really [ __ ] good podcast and I
haven't lost my mind Logan Paul
Logan Paul's podcast really [ __ ]
these got some that
some shy guests on the hill it'll
probably have like a Nicki Minaj or
something
but even so firfer can play us a big
money yeah he had the real wolf of
wallstreet really like giving sales
advice [ __ ]
so anyway and he was talking about all
of the guys in the room we're talking
about the fact that all of them have
pitched themselves into meetings with
people that are super successful and
said that they are the best of social
media in all of LA when they've never
done social media or digital marketing
before me and then they've just had to
learn on their feet and I think that you
can overshoot and this goes back to what
you were saying about just getting
started with something if you're going
to start a business I think starting
small ie do not I repeat do not ring me
that you've remortgaged your entire
house to start a business when you have
no business experience now you start
with a low amount of financial liability
I've seen that before is terrifying
you've never run a business before and
you've put 50% of your net worth into
this business C on dragons done a lot
favor what so people just go people pay
when they take their ask me from when
they haven't made many sales it's like
how much have you invested like a
hundred thousand of my own money every
mortgage my house twice there's this
great optimism I'm going to pay like
once i take off the child support and my
divorce settlement like yeah painful
everybody thinks they're gonna be Levi
Roots don't they well yeah like the one
diamond in the rough success story yeah
but it's it's kind of why the that Gary
Vaynerchuk advice of like you know the
people ask him a question like I'm I'm
29 and I've got this idea but I think
it's too late to start he's like [ __ ]
you like of course it's not too late to
start so well Gary that's fine and until
it's negligent until either person
actually doesn't have a really good idea
and they ruin their life pursuing this
like well I just need to keep trying and
keep investing and keep going so I was
you only know that if you just bought
it's the Facebook thing move move fast
break it and then go by the way so
interesting point here David Epstein
guys that wrote range he said that he'd
done an analysis of when the out of the
average age of this
years of industry changing businesses so
you asked what's the average age of CEOs
and industry changing businesses when
they founded the company so not when it
went public none of that [ __ ] what's the
average agent they asked this at this
like super star dop Silicon Valley
quantified self vegan [ __ ]
conference someone like batter a tip on
the walls basketball hoops everywhere
exactly and loose for loads of food
sport yeah exactly asked this question
and the room was like 23 24 25 because
everyone knows the Mark Zuckerberg story
about he was I think 23 in his side
Facebook average age 44 yeah I told
myself before Bill Gates and that era of
CEOs seemed to play around in a number
of different industries before they get
to something but what have they got
wealth of experience yeah and masses of
failures as well probably
well even even like on a really PG like
a BBC level drug instead again if you
watch that line though like none of them
are such and such founded a business
when he was 18 it was the first business
easier than you went on to be a
multi-millionaire like all of them had
like eight businesses that a pike
spectacularly failed and then the ninth
one just went alright so as a to try and
give some of my Genesis story I guess
with this which is a little bit country
to what we said so far the first-ever
business that I started was when I sat
down at my first seminar for uni in
freshers week sat next to my business
partner when would be business partner
said I'm skint I spent all of my money
in freshers week drinking this is when
like maintenance alone was like three
two and a half grand or something in
pennies but then also accommodation was
also pennies that's that next sermon he
said are well there's this company that
used to work for an elite called voodoo
now you can come and get a flyering job
with me later on like trying to come to
the meeting this week and then from then
we started working together and that
that was my first ever business
first day of university sat next to my
business partner 13 years later still
together still there's a key difference
there though isn't there as to why that
was successful and the people who quit
their job and remortgage the house
before they've fathered an idea why that
was successful with that very delicately
threaded in and moved up through the
business so definitely one of the
principles I think that people need to
keep a hold of is that if you've never
run a business before or if you're
wanting to start a business you have to
as far as I'm concerned especially small
businesses if you are a specialist in
logistics or something like that there's
no reason that you couldn't after a lot
of time doing logistics then jump from
perhaps management to ownership that's a
fairly easy one but for a lot of SMEs my
best bit of advice in terms of starting
is to learn every phase of your business
from the ground floor up yeah so the
lineage of the typical club promoter
would be starts a flyboy be good at
flyering
then maybe become like a senior flyboy
where you manage the other PR staff then
junior event manager event manager
senior event manager city manager maybe
business development manager or
something like that then director and
once you've done through all of those
different stages you understand you've
got a bird's-eye view of recruitment of
marketing of HR of accounting of b2b or
b2c at all that sort of [ __ ] and then
when one of your employees comes to you
with an issue you can deal with it
because you have seen like an every
single thing and you've got process so
there we go another principle is as you
move through the business as you
encounter particular issues write down
your solution that you gave to those
issues because now for me and Darren
again one of the things that we talk
about with our businesses that were not
actually that good at business but we've
made 13 years of mistakes that we only
made once yeah and now we have a process
for there's very rarely very very rarely
that I come up against and
we'll be percent I know it's the same
for you guys because I've seen your
autoresponder email the very rarely do
you encounter a situation after running
a business for maybe more than five
years
which you haven't encountered before
there's something quite symbolic about
that as well that the vast majority of
problems that people believe is this
unique curse bestowed upon them alone
actually just really representative of
what everyone suffers with we get that
with because we we offer business
coaching as well and sometimes you'll
get an inquiry from someone that's like
hey guys I was gonna sign a few program
but my situation is like really unique
and different and special so I need
customized I need something that's more
bespoke and then they describe that
situation you like that was the most
standard businesses like you and the
other ten people who emailed this week
with exactly the same gun from Pacific
yeah did you listen to the T agra fort a
podcast he said that his first type of
business was fixing people's Windows XP
computers everyone had this very unique
problem yeah I came to him we're just
Google no no you just did but installed
the operating system I did restart he
gave it to them how do some they're like
really what's the problem that you've
got oh yes it's difficult when they it
doesn't exactly one solution well it's
all like there's something to be said
for that
like in offering any service obviously
by like background is in delivering
health care service but it's the same
thing that there is there is an evidence
basis behind and this is seen behind the
wall now behind when a doctor asks you
Oh God
this is how medicine works yeah the
doctor will ask you what what do you
think it is okay Kevin II particularly
big worries is that the same as when a
policeman pulls you over and goes do you
know I've pulled you hang on me I'm
[ __ ] home stirring myself
[ __ ] off man yeah like that there's the
three evidence-based questions I ain't
no Gracia I'm not a [ __ ] gratzman
that will improve like patient
satisfaction is you just ask them what
do you think it is any big concerns
what's your expectation for today ice
now doctor doesn't care about your
answers the data shows that that makes
people happier so with service like what
Tiago was doing there rather than being
right right don't care what I'm gonna do
is understand the operating system
instead it's like mmm okay so tell me
how is the Nutella checked and I'm
taking notes on it and then doing what
you want because doesn't matter to them
it's the black box Thiago's come in to
fix my computer I'm happy I'd far rather
that they didn't even ask me you just
fix it really because I'm that rather I
just feel like I think these something's
going on I think you're very unemotional
when it comes to this stuff which again
like being an emotional in business like
now I think I have quite emotional
you're quite transactional with stuff
though you just want in input process I
want the outcome yeah yeah but it's it's
idiocy you want anything else because
you know that when you open a fix a
computer
I want to fix precisely what you're
paying it for yeah you don't like on
this thing [ __ ] imagine you've given
the key to the house and you'd be like
yeah I don't know I cut a story about it
if there's fixing computer so you know
so we've got a myth revisited and just
just thinking basically describes
exactly what you just said email what
you've one of the three stages even
you're the technician when you start
yeah okay the Wrights it it'll be in the
show know the entrepreneurial myth so he
describes a situation of this woman who
works for works in a baker's loves
baking cakes she like right when a satyr
my own bakery set up her own bakery
because she loves making cakes and then
realizes like oh [ __ ] I need to like
clean the surfaces do the books I've got
I need to set up all these systems and
do and manage my advertising and I need
an employee so that she brings someone
in to help and the manager then does
everything pies water systems and ten
years later it's this massive bakery and
she goes in and tries to speak to one of
the employees
employers who you and she and she's like
I baked a cake but there's no like I
don't know that this is how we do it
she's lost complete control the business
because she didn't do every step so it
that is 101 like if you want to if you
look at this because I think that the
the most common movement into business
from those people is they are doing
something or they see the way something
is done and think I can do that or I can
do that better or whatever but they
often miss like the rest of the picture
it's the same as what we talk about a
lot here which is a lot of people want
quick fixes they want the fat loss pill
not to consistently do calorie deficit
with it's not hard your mouth uterus
dieting yeah yeah and it's the same for
this people love the idea of being an
entrepreneur or a business owner more
than they like the idea of doing
business means they want the title
without the graft and unfortunately the
titles only work if the title could be
attained overnight in that case it's not
worth anything so you shouldn't want it
Ronnie Coleman was right all along
everybody wants to be a poet however if
the body mother but nobody want to lift
no heavy housework they don't
everybody want to be a business you
realize slowly that he is just
everything he said you look at him think
what do what a weird outfit nothing but
a peanut butter peanut just this
unbreakable attitude of white doesn't
matter
it sees the impermanence of life through
everything
it's not steam difficulty and like
really start to a peanut yeah and it's
like there's a man about the squat 800
solid ice bath solid US pounds and you
still go like that's really heavy
look it's incredibly should do business
mentor II know Ronald Coleman business
mentors yeah he's [ __ ] now is he but
he but even still like I've seen him
have you seen his YouTube channel so
it's Niek sup behind people well yeah
like Ronnie Coleman supplements calm or
whatever yeah yeah something like can
you imagine hero being one of the staff
that works at Ronnie Coleman supplements
yes can you
yeah exactly your [ __ ] is Ronald in the
building be a bit of a worry that white
no one knows we just ran out of cash and
not realize I think that that's how that
business went I mean I know having seen
the Ronnie Coleman documentary that he
is spending a lot of money on pain pills
yeah it's like a lot of money sighs
bouncing off the limiter of how much you
can take in terms of pain pills you
order them in from the UK there's me
your access now yeah actually also
please get in touch
hang on Ron congratulations Yusuf's a
doctor finally double high five three
two one
Congrats man thank you you should them
that you should have special memorial
catch up for Yusuf's education career
yeah how many eleven so how many years
you've been in full-time education like
the vast majority that's it sorry Ted
yeah and then full-time any higher - no
like that but since you were like plus
the baseline that you have to do was it
five for 11
no plus College so now what time you
like five five until 18 you did such
another 13 okay yeah so let's say lot
laws no isn't it and none of it had any
relevance for the stuff that for any
success okay so there we go there's
another one all three of us did business
or business related degrees conventional
education like so Anton seek alternative
I will put in the show notes I will put
anton Krillin up what some ovens I will
put so puts our ovens in a fermion
already we have made some ground I mean
I watch him but I'll put him in the
church as Christie could imagine
Sam if you're listening you just need to
get laid man like ah his latest video
he's got like long hairs and mass and
he's clearly just be in the hole no
women in it is a there is no women don't
be a virgin and a sex offender like yes
yes I don't want to be sex offender oh I
see yeah anyway back to business so I
think we're definitely one of the things
that you've touched on that which is
super important is if you want to become
good at business a formal education is
in no way mandatory I think it's
unhelpful because it's a waste of time
that you could be spending doing other
things like the ability to learn and
assimilate information is the useful
part but the content least you have to
learn the business degree is useless we
added a module in entrepreneurship
because I did one did you it was like I
turned up nose totally miss advertised
basically it was like the history of
entrepreneurship in the 1930s America
and like there was nothing applicable
here just like you do in marketing or
mustard
yeah there's up teas that masters never
want really never once so the reason
that I did a extra degree of post-grad
was because I knew that the first half
was covering things that I'd done my
degree it was the same some of the
modules were given the same names that I
just finished in my third year so wasn't
evening yeah so I was like okay just
re-purpose my existing coursework that I
did either one of the last three years
and then sure enough did that the only
thing I needed to do was a dissertation
at the end of it yeah I mean that's
that's obviously how much I concentrated
on it
I can remember you doing this situation
like remember being in the flat while
you were doing the dissertations if not
36-hour period yeah that was a 230
people in this world the ones you did
the dissertation in 36 hours and then
once you do in a year yeah I did mine in
36 out so you have 10 Red Bulls and yeah
and all the rest of them they didn't got
done gone finished it yeah so yeah I
don't think formal education at all need
it's like it's not a prerequisite if I
was to design someone that was going to
be good at business they'd be good at
selling yeah copywriting have a good eye
for
it is all just marketing isn't it yeah
we've emailed people you'll be good with
people going up cooking mm sales or
marketing really is this communication
isn't it it's the ability to communicate
a concept idea message but it's
different so advertising and marketing
are quite distinct yeah and advertising
is a important part of new business but
yet so formal education again I was
doing a business degree and very quickly
became disenfranchised disenchanted with
academia because at the age of 18 is a
fresher in uni I was being shown one
particular world of business in
academics and experiencing another and
there was no overlap you slowly realized
the people teaching you about business
have never had any success in business
what the [ __ ] would they be teaching you
for if there were a sensible business
hunter on again we need that clip we
leave our children in the hands of these
[ __ ] failure eight hours a day and
have a successful relationship or
wealthy
how many teachers are millionaires from
teachers yeah I think teachers do very
though this is not this views do not
represent mine
Joseph's or Johnny's all that modern
wisdoms they're just Reaper trying to
Anton but he won't get your email little
Singaporean right wife night pass it on
to us
Mary's on Twitter anyway so yeah you are
right that one of the things that's a
little bit weird is when I look at
America and I see you could go learn
psychology from dr. John Peterson or you
can go and learn like evolutionary
biology from Nicholas Christakis or
astronomy from professor maybe Frank we
really incredible age isn't it like you
can now just have full access to the
best teaching anywhere you mean in the
American University just education
because they'd all those guys up until
not long ago University of Waterloo
still hard dr. sue me go okay I mean up
until five years ago you could go learn
biomechanics from dr. sue mackimmie can
do it all online dollars that's what I
mean like well again so if you want to
find out about that stay tuned for the
week of
third of August Scot hate young on his
new book ultra learning will be coming
out I've recorded it but I can't release
it you said I can't release it but
that's self-directed learning being able
to learn the Fourier MIT computer
science program in six months passed the
exam but enough sorry in one year pass
the exams he was doing one module per
week and a half
well I if I remember I had a lecturer at
uni who was basically like best mates
with the two guys there's something
called an aero debris model in economics
and they like use teaching this thing
and then you look at this alone with
this more face nobody was even that
brilliant but you look up on Wikipedia
arrow-debreu model and there's a photo
of arrow-debreu and the bloke teaching
it in the middle of Sanitation in France
having a coffee but so like he's evicted
but they didn't want theoretical
economics like I'm sure to him and I'm
sure in some way that does be through
into progression but like has that
helped me in my life no not really
if your goal is not to be an academic
then it instantly becomes an AC a
accountancy qualification I do think is
worth it well you have to view it so so
basically in doing an AC a you are put
into so you're learning you're trained
to be an auditor a century of our
businesses but in that process you well
if you do audit add an accountancy firm
and do your AC at the same time then
you're doing your spending a lot of time
in in businesses usually pretty big
businesses and as long as you try and
learn how they were running and see what
they do like everything down from like
how is a new employee added to the
system to like how do they process a
payment or run all the way up to the top
of how the financial statements are
prepared you have to want to learn about
that stuff it doesn't get put upon you
but I think that is of everything I've
done those three years were the most
valuable but even then I'd be coaching a
strike the most valuable thing is
everything I've learned two hours
good night marketing and selling compare
away from some directed stuff yeah what
you've had to stumble through well okay
so we started and we have no clue but
not a clue because how did you begin to
monetize so people will be listening
they'll think oh I could do this I draw
I could do I sing or I am good at
writing or arbitrage in batteries so
that yeah that's an interesting point
because we when we started internet was
much younger like a year in Internet
Landis obviously ten years ago yeah and
so we started in 2008 2009 we're by vert
by dint of just creating a blog and
posting content it would start to reach
the top page liking YouTube six years
ago yeah well like the podcasts now and
so like yeah if you look old-school
YouTube things like power thirst and
those kind of old-school viral videos
that just went crazy because they were
the only content quality but yes there's
Mir advantage so instantly like by just
by having a website you suddenly are
seen as an authority and it's very
demand driven for us so we started to
get inquiries just off the back of that
so we didn't we then were almost spoiled
by not having to learn marketing and not
having to do anything apart from create
content and you're just getting organic
traffic through the blog post yeah then
you write something isn't performing art
on caffeine Ramadan Robert Robert
whereas no that strategy would just
absolutely not work and I've seen people
set up a blog or a YouTube channel boom
and really plot money into it and try
and get the production quality working
and just get nothing out of it because
you can't rely reliably on organic
traffic being a thing not anymore
yeah I mean this is your area and I'm
sure we will get onto this again I'm
gonna keep on rinsing this because this
series is new for us but we could do I
mean I could leave you guys to do five
episodes on your own about Facebook ads
paid marketing how it ties in with org
and all that so this is it and
unfortunately you have to be a polymath
of all of those things you have to know
SEO web design more
in content creation communication Mach
Facebook ads Google ads even you have to
read all of these different moving parts
of the business accounts operations you
have to really know all of that stuff I
got a basic level ask Youssef anything
about WordPress just ask him a question
they're like say something like oh I
think this about WordPress you'll either
get angry valid yeah I'll do this for
the listeners that is a short intake of
breath with the lips person and then
pulling apart it's like you might see
him do it yeah things get heated you'll
see him do it but I think so that that
got us to the point where we were making
like probably like a coupler so I
remember I remember this conversation
with someone at uni where we'd like we
did this blog on the side and we had
four grand in the bank account really
clearly remember the amount and someone
went like do you guys even like what do
you mean do and I'm like oh we've just
made like our first like four thousand
pounds on him what what the [ __ ] like
that
how have you done that like how did you
do that so that what were you selling we
got up to that point well and console
table yeah when you started with a right
apartment which it was not so how long
were you
what was this Skype call that was a week
of you got a training plan diet plan and
coaching for a week that's a little boy
severe like right open up a document of
Microsoft Word
God name was it and with three of us
coach this person at once I figure we
had a gold plan that was a hundred quid
and a platinum that was two hundred
fifty quid that wasn't a death of
planning that was iolo's
so this is this is probably the iconic
story of propane so driving the gym one
morning still uni on the way a train
butl oom-pa-pah notification 250 pounds
why do you suppose I you said someone's
just bought platinum and obviously
you're upset and laughter because
platinum didn't it what the [ __ ]
platinum so I then didn't train and have
to sit and make this guy which was
basically just like my like one o'clock
of every
I was interested in at the time with you
drew a graph about the quarters I did up
a graph thought I was really a bit more
it was just like everyone [ __ ]
Dominica nice guy - what was he
turnaround time I did it that day one
day yeah - nifty go ahead - road to quit
even still because I was bursting like
he was used coming up my Paul was this
stuff I have read so much about it but
yeah and then but I think we never
really got above we would never been
able to do it full-time if we omit
Lincoln never really got any point where
it was meaningful until we learned
marketing and the first market we spend
a thousand quid on a course report on
how to do in Emile Emile Markham so you
know you were saying it's a series of
problems that you solve yeah so the
bottleneck was revenue to say I'm not
coming in so we think so what was that
due to traffic due to volume well yeah
like a traffic handle conversions both
balance it said to improve both from the
from the traffic improved it from the
course from the marketing course also
the new improved traffic and conversions
then suddenly you've got revenue coming
in more client demand but we can't
actually K to sue them here so we end up
just getting less and less sleep and
taking more sales calls at like 2:00 in
the morning to somewhere in America and
like just you can see on the videos
there's a period in my youtube channel
where both me and Johnny just start
looking more solemn have you ever seen
Brian Cox go into a centrifuge can you
make can you make Brian Cox okay in the
centrifuge pH just here please it's like
you but it's yeah hang on actually
someone someone called us out on one of
the videos and said I swear that you say
video guy Dean's going to do loads of
things that he doesn't do
[ __ ] body organs we'll find out what
actually so yes um you were saying so
yes it is a series of problems that sold
and we've solved one bottleneck it
opened up then the capacity problem
they've been the seats you deliver that
service to the clients and we just
didn't have a scalable system to deal
with it and so which is like a rope you
see people is much more gentle but yeah
see you finally it's like you be me be
like underneath attack for ages of the
screwdriver my trying to unplug it and
you unplug it's a very different problem
of life the house is gonna flood the
house is flooding your I've run out of
buckets yeah that's the best analogy
because it's suddenly a problem that you
you've only got a screwdriver to try and
fix the water so we ended up
sleep-deprived I'm just feeling
horrendous what year was this 20 2014
yeah oh yeah and it was only really
having Chris's advice and a series of
mentors and business coaches that we
hired over the following few years that
finally got us to develop a scaled
leverage approach to delivering service
to clients without them suffering like
they actually got a better service as a
result rather than them getting like a
sleep-deprived coach that writes them
out of program that they halfway through
Ramadan yeah yeah Robert you've got my
dollar profit or on my bond so I think
that that the lesson the business lesson
from that is and I think this is what
took us a long time to realize is that
you don't really people like people set
up a company and do something really
manually themselves and think I have a
business but if they went on holiday
of all of the aspects of the business
from like selling delivery everything's
stopped that's just a job with loads of
risk with a mellow holiday pay no
pension you know maternity or paternity
leave probably well I work in cafe near
oh man so I'm my own boss I you have got
nothing in the way of systems or an
actual business so for it to be a
business you have to be able to you not
do the southern and it still sales still
happen not bring in the traffic or the
attention and that still happens not
actually deliver the product and that
still happens and only when you I slowly
step away also
yeah you do it it's kind of a little bit
I imagine it is for me like putting a
baby to sleep
I have very slowly of stepping out of
the room like the handle closing it
allowing it to just but in a bit alike
but that's them sometimes you just hear
a thud from inside the river
oh no babies falling out or what I can
allow bang yeah telling them don't know
what's under the baby like grenade so
good a couple of good stories to start
framing this I guess the principle we
should probably try and either before or
after a principal try and summarize it
and I guess what we're talking about
here is the art of delegating or the art
of scaling because the art delegating is
a massive topic that we need to get onto
which is bringing in people who fill in
the gaps in your particular skill set
and that's probably a full episode on
its own but a fairly charming story to
do with this is I worked 204 Saturdays
in a row without stopping didn't miss a
single Saturday so when we were years of
oh yeah so when we first launched our
first half a weekly event that was the
what is good to the listeners at home
Yusuf is the lift it is like a meow like
a cat at a repair you've punched your
pants damn right I mean story that's
gonna have to be cut out isn't it
just believe it in videoman Dean will
have cut all this out by now as long as
he's put something over your crotch
so I worked I worked over 200 Saturdays
in a row without taking a break that
included that wasn't just me working on
the nighttime and being kind of the
slightly more Swan around boss I am now
that was getting up at 10:00 in the
morning going to the club for 11 a.m.
putting up the inflatable thing that
goes up in the main room like plugging
in all of the DJ decks upstairs like a
job which with a written process could
have taken anyone three hours to do
would have cost us 18 quid a week but oh
no because I was terrified I was so
neurotic about the business and I think
this is something which if I can do this
well for someone else I think we'll the
problem is if you want a job doing
properly do it yourself absolutely is
true
yeah and the conversation that I had to
pardon me with Stephen Wolfram the other
week was he a lot of the time because he
understands coding right from the ground
floor he goes into Wolfram language or
wolfram mathematica and just checks out
the code so he'll go on to like Wolfram
Alpha calm and just look at the code and
just coat-check [ __ ] and debug [ __ ] and
you like hang on you're the CEO 800
people work on this do you know who
wrote that bit of code like some spotty
teenager in San Francisco who works off
his like out of his mom's basement or
something like that because everyone's
remote pretty much in wolfram and you
got the CEO going in there just being
like let's drop him an email and be like
oh just checked out the code there's a
little bit of debugging to be done in
here ten minutes and he'll do it but the
problem there is that he has served his
life so that he can do that because
that's what he loves yeah but that's not
the way that most people would want to
run a business they you know
he's not character the kisser no sir
yeah very sentence life so that he can
code more whereas most people want to do
it so they can do less oh yeah like what
we're saying about the the e-myth
concept is that you graduate from
technician to franchise owner where
actually you're not breaking the bread
at all you don't even see the flour
anymore
you wrote the process and then someone
else is carrying it home and you've got
people are immobile so the day I quit or
maybe like the week before I quit so sad
laughs I don't know December time
KPMG sat in where nobody can see but
behind the camera in this mystical land
of this is assessed because let's not
forget that this isn't actually my
living room
this is a podcast studio built to look
exactly like my living room but that's
actually just all open walls there in
the black space we made of a cardboard
so yeah it's just this is going to
become like as famous as like the
casting couch isn't it so might give me
someone you know and I want to come I
want to come up and wanna see the sea I
want to come up and see the the couch
you know when I want to sit where Johnny
sit there was you don't want to sit
where Johnny said yeah huge it was a
thing on Facebook for ages where people
uploaded like the famous that's how I
was set on Facebook and the caption was
like every guy in the UK knows exactly
what this yeah you like yeah I'm seeing
another one I've seen another one with
the real thing that's for sale all right
Lauren was in fake taxi ah female fake
taxi what's her stage name sienna day
the other day anybody wants to have a
watch of some adult entertainment just
before this is with Chris's made in it
yeah porn hole she made a big time then
see Anna that she don't good man she
don't do it two wheeler doesn't
hierarchy that's that's totally written
what is that what was I saying
what's a huge behind that i sat there
and you said to me I used to tell people
to go to clubs now I tell people who
tell people who tell people to go to go
to clubs
okay I think I understand that no yeah
but that is actually the goal isn't it
the only reason why if he wanted to be
Wolfram about it was if you really liked
giving people flyers yeah then you'd be
like you know what one day a week I'm
gonna go down Northumberland Street and
give up flies but what you would have
done then is you would have brought in
everybody else that did everything that
wasn't giving up flyers
so the business still mmm act on your
behalf
you've just about 70 flyers so if you
were the early flag if we don't give
that money out man print print media is
dead there we go a business principle
print media [ __ ] off great no one looks
at a flyer anymore under the rotating
elastic bands that justify as flies it
actually I'm gonna do with we can do a
little quick fire round a finger about a
stud and we've got a lot of outtakes at
the beginning so I think we're about
maybe 50 minutes in couple of things
just some quick principles off the bat
male shots through the door as far as
I'm concerned if you are launching your
business nah [ __ ] off
no one wants you're like if you put junk
mail through someone's letterbox you're
probably just either wasting money are
damaging your brand how do you feel
about join me later
absolutely terrible I mean we've we've
heard if you've not heard the light as
it life fails where we talk about
there's a township oops catch up yeah on
his letterbox he has written no joke no
joke well because never has there been a
more effective deterrent job is to give
you joke mail it was a well the only
people that get through are 18 at Farm
Foods no I used to have that warmth oh
yeah you've got the psyche on the other
side of your door I'm have a sack and I
chased people down the road if they and
then you have a musket like his goes
across the top of the Yeti your Yeti
that's in there actually you've just got
the line of sight is directly slimmer
lots of people so don't email shots
don't do dirty brain print media's
[ __ ] dead man like unless you are a
club promoter who has one advantage that
we have but between the hours of 10:00
p.m. of 1:00 in the morning the only
people that exist on the street are our
crowd so our markets been filtered by
temporarily and spatially great I can
race if you're walking if you're walking
through
Newcastle's big market or Manchester's
Deansgate 12 midday a translator
12 12 midnight like you're there because
you're you ready to go on a night out
and if you're not ready to go on a night
out retargeting this isn't up so this is
technically an upsell or cross-sell I
see we need to map this out and lucid
charts real but yes so print media
[ __ ] dead I wouldn't I would really
would not waste your time with it that
would include big advertising like if
you have a look at the price to get JC
Dekker oh yeah and you've got minimum of
like 10 sites minimum of this many weeks
there's many exposures and it's like
unless you selling the new [ __ ] Kia
Picanto so yeah I think traditional
media with regards to that like you can
sell so well just off the back of
becoming your own brand and we can move
into personal branding humanizing the
brand all that sort of stuff so I have
some points on the rise the the basics
of this would like if you sat listen to
this and you're thinking so this isn't
for people who have a business who are
looking to prove it's for people who are
like working that be next episode
that'll be one of the future yeah we
could say we could do to start if we're
moving through chronological scale etc
the million excited scale
love scale so people I think you know
the whole garyvee thing of like there's
never been a better time to start the
business the best time to start business
with ten years ago well your second best
time is today yeah but I do not is not
trading yeah second motorcycle is
definitely a place for business as well
isn't it but but it's so it's so easy
like you if you just want to replace
your income by doing something you enjoy
doing
you can absolutely sell some kind of
expertise or even sell what you're
currently doing but package it in a
business so the point of written here is
that people don't do it because they
think jobs are the safe route I have
quite a nihilistic view on this but I
think realistically most jobs will be
automated within ten years the vast
majority especially [ __ ] like finance
accountancy anything admin like
realistically is not the safe I can't
see oh yeah absolutely it's illicit The
Economist thinks it's like one of the
most likely industries order painting
and like plumbing and [ __ ] like that cop
carpentry those are the most safe
industries but well but painting I
wonder if they're gonna have this that
drone that comes in the room it's just
that this is this everywhere every
reason every room the different
dimensions and people have very specific
requirements so you you use the Dulux
app where you fill insert in the walls
it detects the walls it maps out like
the the lines and stuff and it just
flies around and just why not go
orthogonal with this and just everyone
get VR to the point where it's such high
quality if the other thing changes the
things in your room well a son okay his
I was not I don't you live your life
just lying Abed don't know if there we
go
I can't hear us I can't my family
everybody so far you know every nice
have a rest
yeah I'd love a rest so sell whatever
you're doing like there is an
opportunity to do that and there are a
few resources Edison too so there's an
Alan Watts video it's not right I did
not expect he just as much wisdom
yeah really where he taught he talks
about like how to decide what to do and
he uses an example of like room
you're like what to do you can command a
good fee version you like what you do
and if you do it for the money that's
madness and so he talked about that and
just basically logically walks you
through like why working in a job that
you don't like because you think it's a
safe route his lunacy I'm Tom creel the
clip from that I assume you're gonna
share it's already been in one spot has
it so that that video convinced me
you've got my job why he talks about
viewing view and quitting your job to
start something in a trading analogy so
he's like look at your downside on your
website so you win 20 grand a year and
you want to start your own business you
quit your job people think I have a
downside or I stand to lose 20 grand a
year actually you probably start to lose
like 2 grand a year because you could go
back into a job for 18 let's say you're
upside is potentially unlimited it's
like let's say you quit and you become
the next Jeff Bezos unlikely but
possible like never gonna happen in your
current situation might happen if you
quit and try so you're exposing yourself
to unlimited upside with it by a to
brand downside cuz then if that is it's
like if you fail after say yeah you only
can find another job yeah worst case you
can find a job for a bit laughing yeah
the asymmetry in that particular trade
if any traders saw that opportunity take
it every day mother familiar margin so
he just says put yourself in situations
like that for the rest of your life and
you'll become very wealthy very wealthy
indeed what woods if I got down there
you got anything else I mean not going
like emotional management [ __ ] it so but
yeah so I think don't don't I I was
going to stay in a job that I did I was
told by everyone around me was the safe
route because you know quitting and
starting your thing is stupid and many
of your co-workers are still there still
that yeah and some of them some of them
liked it some of them don't but I think
by let's say like our parents generation
wait for them to start a business really
difficult to do a lot of areas to enjoy
will do very very high friction like you
need to produce a widget in a factory
and you know get a
from a bank late very traditional now
you can essentially sell information
digitally for and make a good good
income doing it so why if you have an
inkling of thinking about it at least
[ __ ] give it a go
the other thing as well as the most
businesses like this like you did you
were able to do multiple things at once
yeah if you are looking to do something
that occurs very specifically within
office hours you've seen that in your
particular area there is a market for
window cleaners let's say and you ask
about it you happen to have the
expertise or the inclination who's
[ __ ] love again after windows and
you're like right but I've got a 95 in
some typical retail store ok you just
you've got a little bit conflict whereas
for the most part what we're gonna be
talking about here is some small sort of
craft someone's unique skill or a
marketing opportunity or coaching or
whatever it might be and there's no
reason that you can't begin to dip your
toe alongside whatever the job is I'm
only me and I think like so the Alan
Watts thing if you just do for a living
what you find intensely interesting then
immediately you have a massive advantage
of everybody else
so like the thing I remember thinking
was I remember sitting in the office and
I wanted to leave a 5 o'clock because I
want to train or to do propane see
friends or whatever other people wanted
to stay something you might well because
I don't want you to immediately bugs are
already starts against yeah I'm gonna
get a notion I'm not gonna be a partner
or whatever so like I'm gonna go find
the thing that I don't mind doing till
midnight that actually I would choose to
do because then even turn it end up in
the top 1% is so great if you did both
of you this to the James clearer podcast
it talks about Steffi Graf so he talks
about Steffi Graf one of the greatest
female tennis players of all time
think she's German and sounds June so
when she was about 12 or 14 they went
and did too broad area tests on the
youth players in the German tennis team
and one of them was on skill and
aptitude and the other was on
passion and motivation and she scored
the highest on both so like right oh
good good [ __ ] look beating her yeah
even if you're more skilled she'll
outwork you at training and catch up and
then overtake you and to her it will
feel like fun another example sara
sigmundsdottir that captioned David's
daughter one of the fittest women on the
planet to the last few years in the
CrossFit Games and someone said to her
how do you find the motivation to do
what you do every day she said if you
gave me any life in the world I would
choose what I'm doing right now
you know I [ __ ] like you try and
beat her we try and will yourself to
beat someone for whom work feels like
fun and that's what James clear says
that if you can find the thing which to
you feels like play but to everyone else
feels like work you're laughing and then
for me at the moment is this podcast and
10 years ago for me it was filling and
running clubs yeah and if you're if you
do it sufficiently well and we can get
onto this lineage a little bit more in
future episodes but if you do
sufficiently well you can do to a much
more successful cessful degree than I
have but you can scale businesses which
you have conquered build them to a
degree whether sufficiently
self-sufficient leave them off to one
side and then take the next conquest on
yeah do other stuff
any like rock a so [ __ ] it now I'm gonna
add a podcast on okay so [ __ ] now I'm
gonna start to do for me
modeling or I'm gonna start to do a DJ
for a while or I'm going to start to do
this or that or the other but the
foundation needs to be a business which
you can scale I mean so you can do this
within so like you don't have to set up
a business just and something you enjoy
like you could so that currently was a
book called so good they can't ignore
you he wrote before all the stuff easier
it is calling you cause yeah yeah yeah
so that he talked about finding so he
talked about he uses the Steve Jobs
thing of like find your passion and how
that's actually not correcting that that
doesn't correlate with happiness and
actually if people have autonomy and
feel good at something if you're valued
they get just as much satisfaction from
a career in a job as it would from a
business you can there's a lot of
examples in that book but you can't get
the same thing from that but most people
I think it's fair to say the vast
majority don't consider work as
something that they
she has used to do love doing 15% people
do apparently love it 15% of people say
that they are actively engaged in their
job right 85% of people are either
actively disengaged or agnostics so grim
isn't about work yeah much especially
don't you think that's 40 hours of your
life
minimum every week plus travel to and
from work plus all of the Mincey stuff
that you've got to do around it that
move like the office politics social
connections that taking your work on
weekends cafe coffee Nescafe coffee
[ __ ] [ __ ] you take out slop pop
up Coco Pops my if you take our sleep
time which is your unconscious so you
can't really count that towards time
spending your life it's such an
overwhelming 50% of your life but I like
the room like on a Friday night just get
like about it because the reality of the
situation is just tear it well when you
think about when you actually really sit
think about each one of Christ yeah I
want to escape it yes I'm gonna go I'm
gonna go out and people often cry drunk
and then get cry and then get cry get
drunk and then cry and then get cry that
may get cry after that yeah and then
Dean drunken Tim herb and Tim Evans
podcaster Tim Ferriss they talk about
happiness and his definition of
happiness is like crushing a Tuesday I'm
gonna mint Tuesday yeah and that's what
this podcast was gonna be called
crushing issues there or do I have to go
and get like but I think if you don't
thoroughly right if you don't regularly
have Tuesdays really like that was good
[ __ ] now then do you do something
else yeah I mean so at the beginning of
the next episode some of the listeners
will be familiar with this but beginning
of the next business principles I'm
going to do the experiment you can do a
home where you whittle away your wage
down and I'm pretty certain that if we
ask it enough questions we will be able
to get you to pay us to come to work I'm
pretty sure the way I would do that so I
think we might as well call it there
that I really enjoyed this I think that
a lot of people are interested in
entrepreneurship and stuff like that as
I've already said
if there's areas you want us to cover
[ __ ] me from like scaling specific stuff
and a lot of people have actual
questions about how to run Club promo I
don't don't treat any of our trade
secrets is that secret online marketing
is available everywhere if you want to
know about Facebook ads if you want to
know about staff management problem
solving emotional control how to scale
the business pricing strategy whatever
it is we give the questions yeah if you
are something that's boring to answer in
a podcaster forum okay to answer it but
if it's something this like that cool
well what do you want to know what is it
that you want to know what what
questions have you got either about sort
of personal questions for our particular
career history yeah
gives a message as always thank you very
much for tuning in like share subscribe
I would really appreciate it okay bye
[Music]
you